but there's a clip here two clips that
we'll kind of do back to back net
there's this comedian out there if you
can pull up this clip and they basically
talk about men back in the day basically
our grandparents the 1940s versus men
now we got volume Jorge
let's do it let's do it
but the Battle of Normandy came home and
worked to provide for my family the only
time I complained was when I woke up
screaming in my sleep well as a
stay-at-home mom I mean Dad I ensure
that my two kids Zeon and ziblat live in
a world without boundaries every day my
wife gives me a to-do list and a to not
do list but mostly I just have to sit
back and zip it till a feminist driven
sexually liberated Society takes my
family to a better where's my freaking
iPad oh my gosh I'm sorry my little love
pudding I Fought the Battle of annoying
all right cool shout out to the comedian
Andrew Oporto very good talking about
men uh back then versus men today
basically the feminization of men uh
ladies have been basically talking about
how men need to be more masculine be
more of a fighter UFC fighter to be
exact uh who would you rather have been
with out of those two guys oh the first
guy but wait there's something we need
that I want to talk about like why are
men feminized like can we get I want oh
yeah yeah we could talk I mean okay
sorry yeah go ahead okay I just want to
talk about the feminization of meant
like why they feminize especially off
the back of the the first video you
played
um there's two reasons why men are
feminized we have we live in a femme
Centric Society right so men are being
raised by and also because of the
breakdown of the family unit and there's
a war on the family unit so men are
being raised by women right and
um when they're not um at home then
they're in school being taught and
raised by women
um in a world whereby everything is
catered to women
um whereby the messaging from the media
is don't you know don't be toxic
masculine don't be toxically masculine
don't you know it's okay to cry it's
okay to show your feelings
um you know so they're like pushing all
this like feminine energy
um onto men and I don't think that is
just a uh a coincidence I think the
reason they're doing that is because
for as we saw from the video many used
to be a lot more masculine they used to
be a lot stronger they used to be a lot
more disagreeable
um and so it's the men that go to war
and it's the men that fight so when
tyranny comes it's the men that go first
right and so if you're able to um
control the men and you're able to
feminize the men then you're able to
control Society to a much greater extent
um you know especially with the last two
years
I spoke up a lot about how I found the
vaccine mandates inhumane the lockdowns
inhumane and that went against my nature
like as a woman I don't want to be at
War like I went to war but like you know
online or whatever I don't really want
to go to war but like I felt like I
needed to I mean if we lived in a
society whereby like men were more
masculine and they weren't busy with
their rainbow flags and switching
genders and all that fun stuff
um you know I don't think that like the
last two years would have gone as far as
it did basically
um you know if men were more masculine
so when you when you feminize the men
you control Society better
um and again that's why we have all
these firm-centric systems so that's
basically what's going on and yes I'd
rather marry the first the first man the
one from the 1940s but even then I won't
go on but even then I don't think we had
it right in the 1940s either right and
that's and here's where I'll go with
that anytime there's a situation that
needs to be corrected Corrections happen
correct okay whether that's in
masculinity whether feminine entity
whether that's the workplace whether
that's politics they notice that
correction needs to be needed like first
wave feminism feminism yeah women should
vote
yeah women should be able to drive right
yeah women should be able to work
Corrections okay politics Corrections
okay I I didn't like Obama we're going
to correct it with Trump we didn't like
Trump we're going to correct it with
Biden Biden ain't doing so hot we're
gonna probably correct it boom so the
problem is when you have these
Corrections you start correcting and
correcting and correcting and next thing
you know there becomes an over
correction okay so I guarantee you five
years ago there were not these types of
topics being discussed throughout social
media because it wasn't that big of a
problem and the problem was exacerbated
during covet and lockdowns and
compliance and Order and all that stuff
and clearly we're in need of an over
correction so a lot of young men out
there who are basically saying you know
what I think I was kind of [ __ ]
raised by my mom and feminine it's like
time for me to man up I watch an Andrew
Tate video and I was about to [ __ ]
off myself and you know what I got a
six-pack now so you talked about you
know the need of a correction sometimes
over Corrections need to be corrected
correct is that over correction 100 I
mean I think it we need that so much
because as I said and you mentioned as
well we yeah we have these fem Centric
societies so if a man
um doesn't know what he's doing in life
and he can't find his purpose he's being
raised by his mother and she's like it's
okay it's okay don't worry you know
you're okay get in touch with your
feminine side it's okay to cry here's a
trophy for being in seventh place boom
and then they say and I quote Jordan
Peterson as well here Jordan Peterson
says you know these women in society
tell men you're okay the way you are no
you're not okay the way you are nobody
is okay the way they are yeah even women
then that's a major issue which we can
get to as well why most women are still
singles because all their all their
babes are like yeah you're yeah girl you
don't need to lose weight you're okay
the way you are no you're a boss babe
nobody's okay the way they are everybody
if you want the best you got to do
better and improve and get the best okay
Ally oh I've got a lot of it's been some
game girls let these guys know so many
opinions um okay so a masculine man is a
man who cannot be controlled and that is
either a danger or a benefit to society
to women to children but I think right
now it's mostly just seen as a threat
and a detriment because it had all these
masculine men came out and said hey uh
matter of fact we're not we're not going
to comply with these job mandates matter
of fact we're going to stop like Supply
and shipping matter of fact I just
clearly I will not be going to work I
think we would have seen a big and a a
different outcome because to me this
Global pathogen has just been an excuse
for authoritarianism and I know that men
could have stopped it if they wanted to
but I don't think that they are
encouraged to operate in that capacity I
think that we need men but we're trying
to just keep make them wallets only like
the beta bug situation but for a society
and I see that happen on the Progressive
side of things the secular side of
things but I also see it happen on the
Christian side of things too and that's
what makes me really upset because one
of the things that I've experienced my
husband is a non-believer so he's
agnostic I think and I'll get a lot of
Shame for choosing to date a man outside
of the church but if you go and you look
at the church it's a lot of feminized
beta males and that actually goes
against like the biblical Doctrine men
are encouraged to be men women are
encouraged to be women but like like
freaking Ned Flanders on The Simpsons
yeah neighbor yeah and so like me me a
young fertile woman you know I am
Christian but that's not the kind of guy
that I want to date and it's like
they're trying to convince women that
they should be attracted to these more
beta male types and so a lot of young
fertile Christian women are being shamed
essentially but you can't convince me
that God wanted me to marry a feminine
man I'm sorry I I don't care I just
don't think that that's reality so that
that's mostly my perspective and it
seems that what's encouraged globally
with this progressivism and globalism is
that the only right way to be human is
to be feminine so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
foreign
[Music]